hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our
journey paul morphy is still waiting for
his match to uh against howard staunton
to begin and
we are still in paris in 1858 uh playing
some
uh some casual games some challenges and
uh whatever comes along
morphy's way here we have another very
nice game between paul george
and this is a really really wild one so
without further ado let's check it out
and see if
if anyone can take away a single point
from morphe
or not uh let me just
check something real quickly it seems
that morphe's
profile photo uh is uh one
one frame too much uh up all right i
think
that will do it didn't uh realize it
while i was uh shifting them but yeah
that should be that should be okay let
me check that oh yeah that that hit the
spot
uh all right so without further ado
let's check it out as you know with the
white pieces
opens with e4 morphe also replies with
e5 we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and now bishop to c4
uh the italian game is on the board we
have bishop to c5 going for the joko
piano
and now morphy's opponent uh incredible
as it is it does not go for the evans
gambit and
this is uh now in those days this was
clearly
clearly an insult morphy traveled all of
this
weight to be uh you know declined to the
opportunity to to play against the evans
again but but okay if white is not
interested in the best move uh what can
what can uh morphy do about it so
knights the c3
continuing development and the d6 we
have h3 now
uh preventing bishop to g4 and bishop to
e6 by morphy with bishop back to b3
now if morphe wants to trade then white
will get a nice semi-open a file for the
rook
and morphe just continues development we
have knight to f6
d3 and now queen to d7 morphe
also might have some ideas of castling
queenside uh we have kingside castle by
jordan
and here morphy castles kingside
actually
and interestingly this position has been
reached many times in modern games
uh where uh every time a queenside
castle was played but here we have
kingside castle
and it is uh as a movie that this
position has never been
reached again uh so uh white has some
ideas white wants to start attacking uh
he wants to play something like
f4 first move the knight but the bishop
will
prevent that in the future so he starts
um this plan with king to h1
we have h6 by morphy also might have
some ideas of maybe knight h7 knight
shifting to g5 we have knight to h2
and now the f4 pawn can be uh pushed uh
forward as the king is no longer on g1
uh but
morphy doesn't allow it he actually
strikes in the center with the d5 so
what can journal do here
uh well he could capture with the pawn
he could capture with the knight
or he could do what's actually best for
white and that's just
continue expanding with f4 and now
you're already threatening f5
which will trap the bishop so morphy
needs to do something about this he
plays d
captures on e4 uh now removes one of the
defenders of the f5 square and here we
have
f captures an e5 uh we have knight
captures on e5 by morphe
and already on move 12 we have a very
exciting position uh what would you play
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find a really really
strong move for journal while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
immediately going for the attack and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
uh the strongest move here is rook
captures on f6 it was not played in the
game
but it offers some very exciting play
for example if you capture
uh on f6g captures then we immediately
get
knight to e4 uh threatening knight to f6
check which would win the queen and not
a lot you can do here also the bishop is
hanging so
that one move that helps save everything
is bishop to e7 getting the bishop out
of harm's way and also guarding the
f6 square now queen to h5 and then
white just keeps going forward it's uh
it's a very
very unpleasant position for black and
white would most likely prevail bishop
captures and h6 is coming and so on and
also after rook captures on f6 you could
first go after the bishop
uh but uh even that's fine for example a
captures on b3 and now if e captures on
d3
uh uh or still declining to capture the
rook
white can just move back the rook and
it's still a much better position for
example d
captures on c2 queen captures and now
for example morphe could play queen to
d3 and
yes white is up a piece but morphe is up
two pawns so maybe morphy
took all of this in consideration and um
i thought that this was uh in fact in it
and uh well an advantageous position for
him
uh because of course he considers
himself the better player and with his
spawn structure being better he's up to
pawns
uh maybe he thought being down a piece
was fine but who knows uh after this
knight
if i move wouldn't we do not see knight
captures uh rook captures on f6 on the
board
uh instead we have knight to a4
attacking morphy's bishop on c5
uh and now bishop backed b6 uh
and here knight characters on b6 was
played again
a very interesting uh approach to this
opening is bishop captures on h6
uh sorry to the position because now if
you capture then the knight falls with
rook captures on f6
but still after something like rook f2
e8
there's not all that much white can do
here uh this bishop is now just uh
silly looking there the queen doesn't
really have a good way of
uh going into the attack but all of the
knights are covering those squares so we
might see something like
knight captures a captures and now d4
for example pushing back the knight
but then bishop captures on b3 and here
we see
bishop captures on g7 i'm just going to
show it because it's such a fun line
king captures and now this uh d
captures on e5 we sacrifice the bishop
because now we're threatening e captures
on f6 with
checks so black uh does not have uh
uh that doesn't really gain anything by
trading queens now so here we'd see rook
captures on e5
and now after a queen trade for example
captures and captures we'd get a
captures on b3 and now this trade so
we could go into all of this and a lot
of material gets traded down but still
it's definitely black who's better here
so instead after
this uh bishop to b6 move we have knight
captures on b6 just uh eliminating one
of morphy strong pieces
uh eight captures and now d4 uh pushing
back this knight we have knight to c6
and now only now does your no go for
rook captures on f6 and now what do you
play here
uh do you first eliminate the bishop
here or do you first
grab the rogue well uh both has its
merits but morphe decides that it's okay
to capture the rook on f6
we have bishop captures on h6 now
attacking the rook and also you have to
be careful ideas like queen to e1 queen
to g3
check are coming uh morphy says no but
that's not a problem
rook after d8 sorry rook after d8 uh and
now comes queen to e1 now the threat is
just queen g3 check and it's game over
so here knight the e7 uh expecting queen
g3 and then you're gonna just play
knight to g6 so it's not a problem uh we
have queen to h4 by morphe going after
this pawn
uh and uh uh sorry by journal and now
morphe goes for
a knight the g6 and knight to g6 is a
fun move
uh but knight to f5 would have been
better because knight to f5 prevents
any queen captures and f6 ideas because
of the simple
knight g3 check and after king g1 queen
captures here
uh delivers check and also now forces a
queen trade
and since a white is already down
material a queen trade isn't something
you wanna
you wanna meet on the board so instead
after queen to h4 morphe went knights to
g6
now attacking the queen but this
actually allows queen captures on f6 and
okay
you are uh not getting checkmated
because you have this queen captures on
d4
but the the line that we've shown was uh
uh
much much better for morphe because it's
more forcing here queen back to f1
uh of course jordan wants to avoid the
queen trade and now
finally we have bishop captures on b3
this tension has been here
uh in the position for for the entire
game and only now does the morphe trade
with a
bishop captures and c captures on b3 uh
give me one second
sorry about that it was the repairman
but he he missed
the the house he he came knocking on the
wrong door
happens sometimes but yeah after c
captures on b3 we have rook to a5
morphe brings another attacker into the
game but also in this case
a defender because as long as you keep
an eye on this f6 square and you don't
fall for something like
uh queen f6 checkmate you should have a
very
very very good game so here we have
knight to g4
now going for that f6 uh check square uh
but morphy plays the absolute best idea
and that is
f5 so chasing away this knight now the
f6 square is off limits the queen still
covers that
uh and here knight to e3 is the best way
uh to keep the tension on the board but
uh journal played
bishop to e3 he attacked morphy's queen
and now uh there isn't all that much for
for morphe to do he just offers a simple
queen trade plays queen to d3
he's up material so it definitely makes
sense for him to trade queens
uh of course the journal declines this
he goes knight to h6
check king to h7 and now queen to c1 so
still trying to keep the queens on the
board
uh with the bishop defending the knight
maybe queen captures and c7 could open
up some lines for attack
uh but rook to d7 of course morphy
prevents this we have bishop to g5
uh and the now the knight can move the
uh bishop is
well if you can't move anywhere uh for
the moment the but at least the bishop
will not be vulnerable on e3 so the
queen can move and you also kind of need
to bring this rook into the game so here
we have queen the g3
now again putting pressure on the bishop
if the queen moves uh and uh
here comes queen to e3 finally offering
a queen trade because there's
uh there's just no better plan here and
morphe very happily accepts this we have
captures captures and
now uh f4 morphe now continues pushing
those past pawns
uh all right this guy's a past pawn this
guy isn't but you know what i meant
uh so here knight the g4 uh
going for this knight to f6 check but
morphy doesn't care he says nope
that's not going to work he just
captures an e3 we have knight f6 sure
king g7 and now even knight captures
rook here
and now okay he won back some material
but the past pawns are too strong we
have rook to d5 now with the idea of
e2 and rook to d1 check which ends the
game
so rook to e1 uh only good plan
going after the past pawns but now rook
captures on these seven
ah uh if you tried to save the knight
instead of rook to e1
there's no good square for the knight
all of these squares are covered so you
could play something like this but like
we said e2 is it's just game over now
rook to a1 just
rook to d1 and you have to trade
otherwise you you're completely lost
so here and for those of you who don't
know maybe what that means is that white
will have to capture and then black
gets a queen into the game with check so
instead after rook to d5 like we said
rook to e1
one final attempt uh but now morphy just
grabs the piece rook captures on d7
rook captures on e3 and now rook to d4
defending the pass pawn here
uh king to h2 a few more moves were
played we have knight to
h4 and now g4 we have king to f6
now comes a4 but now king to g5
we have king to g3 but this is not too
much and now without even pausing the
video i'm sure you can all guess
morphy's next move
because white by playing king to g3
basically uh
delivered himself into the mating web so
without even pausing the video i know
all you can see it it's
all you can see it it's rook to d2 this
is what morphe played and it was in this
position on move 38 that paul giorno
uh resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
there is no defense against rook to g2
checkmate and
well you could prolong it for a move or
two but still this will be
uh this will be ending in checkmate so a
really wild game that's the second one
we've seen against uh paul george
in this game paul had a really good
chances and by paul i mean the other
paul paul renault
with the white pieces definitely had
good chances and if he went for that
rook captures an f6 idea that we've
mentioned
in the beginning after morphe grabbed on
e5 uh he would have had a decent chance
but like we said
maybe morphy saw all of this and he
wouldn't really mind playing that end
game where he's up to pawns but down a
piece who knows
uh so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna check up on a few
more games um
uh uh while we're waiting for the for
the match with staunton to begin
and the morphe will have some very very
uh strong opponents uh during his visit
to paris uh so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
sandeep menon
ezra taito and in media uh balanced uh
tanka and hunter fike for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
uh and whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day